- Good morning, everybody.
Firstly, if you haven't
got your earphones on,
it will be a good idea.
Then you can hear us properly,
and we won't have
competition from everybody.
So just give me a thumbs
up if you can hear us.
Perfect, thank you very much.
Welcome to a deep dive session
onto ECS Manage instances
and blue/green deployments for
ECS for resilient services.
My name is Maish Saidel-Keesing.
I'm a Developer Advocate with
the developer relations team.
And on stage I have with me.
- Hi everyone.
My name is Malcolm Featonby.
I'm a Senior Principal Engineer
with the serverless and containers org.
Super excited to be here.
- This is a 400 level session,
which means we are assuming
you know what a container is,
you know what ECS is,
and if not, I'm sorry,
this is gonna be very,
very deep in the weeds,
but even though if you haven't
give a slight interview
for slight interlude on what
we're gonna be doing today
on our agenda is we're
gonna have a short overview
of what Amazon ECS is for
those who are not familiar,
but do know what containers are,
and have been using other
container orchestrators.
Then I'm gonna hand it over to Malcolm,
who will give us a good
run through the weeds of
how we're going to actually,
what managed instances is,
and what we've built over
the past period of time.
For a long time, we were
talking about how long ago.
This something, which
has been in the making
for a very long time.
And afterwards, I'll come back,
and we'll dive into how deployments,
with software deployments,
and how you can use those properly
or gain the confidence inside of them
that you can use those two,
deploy your services in a
resilient and available way.
So ECS is,
Amazon ECS is a big service.
We are what we call a tier one service,
which means we are a
prerequisite for any new region
which is built within
Amazon or within AWS.
And it has to be there
because we are a tier one service,
which means a lot of the
services which are built
in each of these regions
rely on ECS to be there in order to run.
We launch more than 3 billion
tasks every single week
across all of our
regions across the globe.
That's a big scale of amount
of service, of how much traffic
and how big the scale,
the service actually,
at which we operate.
Customers that are starting with AWS,
more than 65% of our customers
start actually with using Amazon ECS
because if you already know
how to use Amazon, the APIs,
what the concepts are,
what the constraints are,
you probably really know
how to use ECS as well,
because it's just another
compute option look inside.
Similar to EC2, just running containers.
You don't have to know
any specific systems
or any kind of architecture,
which is different from
how we build the cloud.
And just as an anecdote,
ECS also helps you buy stuff
because in Prime Day as well,
we had more than 18.4
million tasks launched
running on AWS Fargate in order to support
all the traffic, which ran through
on all the different services within,
through Amazon Prime Day as well.
Customers love it.
And these are a couple of customers here,
but it goes across the breadth and depth
of all the different verticals
and different industries today,
customers of all sizes.
These are just a couple of them on screen,
but there's a lot more than
there is, but they're all,
otherwise it would look very, very,
very difficult to understand.
But still.
The reason is because it's a
very simple container service
and allows them to focus on
what we call the most valuable thing
is providing value for
their own customers.
They don't have to worry
about the infrastructure
in the background.
But it's not only customers, as we said.
A lot of the services internally
in Amazon are built on ECS.
Here are a couple of examples.
We have Amazon SageMaker,
Amazon Lex, Amazon Polly,
AWS Batch, and also the
Amazon.com recommendation
for the store.
All of these are built on top of ECS
to provide you those services when you,
when you consume them, either
in the Amazon.com store
or through the AWS console.
And the reason is because it's a very,
service which is built for
security, for reliability,
availability, and of course, scale.
We released something
in September, correct?
Which was Amazon ECS image instances.
I'm gonna hand it over to Malcolm
to start diving into a
little bit of what we did.
- Awesome, thank you.
Thank you so much, Maish.
And thank you all very much
for taking the time to come
and see us, especially,
you know, given that you
chose us over Swami,
we think you made a good choice
and we really appreciate that.
Thank you.
So I have the distinct privilege
of being an engineer
working in the server
listening container space,
and working with the ECS engineering team
on an ongoing basis.
And one of the things that we spend a lot
of time thinking about
is how we can deliver
what we refer to as
how we can deliver
features and capabilities
that can remove what we refer
to as undifferentiated work
from your development teams.
And really what that means is
we wanna be able to make sure
that we're delivering capabilities
which allow your teams to
focus as much of your energy
as you possibly can on
delivering the thing
that makes your product, your service,
your business special for your customers.
And we want to take on as much of the,
as much of the responsibility
and burden of that work
that is important, but not
critical to your business.
So, you know, things like
managing the underlying compute,
making sure that your
EC2 instance is healthy.
And you know, the
infrastructure aspects of that.
And then also helping you with things,
with the complexities of things
like deployment software,
software development,
or software application
lifecycle management, you know,
the deployment of those applications.
And so the team spends a lot
of time thinking about how,
what features we can deliver for you
in order to deliver that behavior.
And this year,
we've delivered a number of features,
but the two that I'm really excited about,
that, you know, we want
to chat to you about
is the one is in the infrastructure,
that's managed instances.
And then the other is the set of features
that we've delivered in
our deployment space,
which Maish is gonna talk to you about.
And the reason that Maish,
when Maish and I were
talking about planning,
what we were gonna speak to you about,
what we thought would be useful is
to explore and give you some insight
into both how the service works,
but also why we designed it the way we do.
The intent here really is
that we want to make sure
that we're baking into
that undifferentiated work,
that we're taking on.
We wanna bake into that the best practices
that we have learned
over the periods of time.
You know, at this point, ECS
has been around for 11 years,
which we're super excited about.
But you know, given that,
as Maish was pointing out,
the number of applications,
the number of services
within Amazon and AWS,
and also in terms of the set of customers,
we've had an opportunity
to learn a great deal.
And so we try and bake
a lot of what we see
to be best practice into the services,
and we wanna deliver that to you in a way
that's easy for you to consume.
So we're gonna dive into
some of these things,
and we're gonna try,
and we're gonna work, you know,
work through how this works
and then point out to those areas,
and we're delivering best practice
in these particular feature sets.
So ECS, in terms of infrastructure,
manages infrastructure,
using a concept that we call,
that we talk about as a compute engine.
And when it was first
launched 11 years ago,
ECS delivered the first compute engine,
which was ECS and EC2.
ECS and EC2 is about bringing
your own EC2 instance.
Effectively, we would
go about orchestrating
the application itself,
but you would bring
your EC2 instance,
and you would manage that.
In 2017, we delivered
our serverless offering
with ECS Fargate,
and that's become very
popular with our customers.
Fargate is sort of on the
other end of that spectrum,
If you imagine that ECS on EC2
is about bringing your own capabilities
and bringing your own EC2 instance.
But then at that, you know,
in that respect, you have to think about
managing that particular instance.
On the other hand of it,
on the other side of that continuum,
you have ECS on Fargate,
where Fargate is taking
on the responsibility
and burden of that,
of the underlying compute for you,
and delivering it to you entirely
in a entirely serverless way,
which allows you to then focus exclusively
on your application.
Now you can think of these things
as two sides of a continuum.
And on the one side you have
a high degree of control,
a high degree of flexibility.
But as a side effect of that,
you also have a high degree of burden
that you're taking on.
You have to think about how to scale,
how to manage, how to patch, et cetera.
And that's ECS and EC2.
On the other side of that spectrum,
you have ECS on Fargate,
where a lot of that complexity
is taken away from you.
But as this trade off, you know,
and this is always true
with managed services,
when you federate a set
of that responsibility
to the managed service,
you're also giving up
a degree of control.
You know, in order for us
to be able to make sure
that we're building the
services so that we can,
we can get you an expected outcome
based any behaviors that we need
to apply to that service.
We need to be able to
make assumptions about
how that service works.
And so we need to be able
to constrain at least
to some degree, the amount
of flexibility that you have.
And so you can imagine, these
two things as a continuum.
And the way we talk about that
in AWS is we talk about it
as the shared responsibility model.
The shared responsibility model is
really the partnership
between AWS and yourselves.
Where we agree which pieces of the stack,
going from, you know, the bare metal,
all the way up to your
application you're looking after,
and which pieces we're looking after.
And so if you look at ECS on EC2,
that shared responsibility
model really is about
us looking after the underlying
infrastructure and compute.
We will make sure that
you have EC2 instances
that are healthy.
We'll make sure that you
have those EC2 instances
in the availability zones that are needed.
We'll provide you storage, networking,
monitoring capabilities,
and then the ECS control plane
where the control plane is,
that management layer
that's actually doing
the provisioning of your application.
But above that, in terms of making sure
that you're order scaled,
making sure that your AZ
distribution, and your spread,
your placement is correct,
launch templates, instance types,
all of that functionality, that behavior,
as well as your application
all becomes your responsibility.
And that can be incredibly powerful
because it gives you
that flexibility, right?
But it also means that when we, you know,
going back to what we were
talking about previously,
our desire to be able to give you options,
to hand off a bunch of
that undifferentiated work,
this is taking on a bunch
of that undifferentiated work, right?
And so on the other hand, we have Fargate.
Now Fargate, on that continuum
of shared responsibility,
actually offloads a lot of
that functionality to AWS.
And that's I think why
many customers really enjoy
the Fargate experience.
You can focus exclusively
on your application.
And as you know,
we then take on the
responsibility of making sure
that you have the server.
In fact, you don't even
have to worry about the fact
that there's a server,
because you're really
just focusing on the app,
on the task, on the ECS cluster,
ECS service, ECS task.
Now what our customers
tell us, and you know,
we get an opportunity to chat you all,
we love that.
And we get that feedback is they love
the degree of flexibility that
you can get on ECS and EC2,
but not super excited about the fact
that you've gotta take on this
additional responsibility.
On the other hand, they love the fact
that there's the simplicity
of management in Fargate,
but would really like an opportunity
to be able to get some of that richness,
that experience, the diversity of choice
on ECS and EC2.
And so in order to respond to that,
we've delivered ECS managed instances.
We're really excited
about this as an offering.
And we really are, you know,
it was delivered in
September, so it's fairly new.
We're very keen to get you get you guys
like having a look at it,
giving it a go, and then
giving us that feedback.
In terms of shared responsibility model,
what ECS managed instances looks to do
is deliver the EC2 flexibility
in terms of choice,
but the Fargate experience.
And so if you look at what we're doing,
we're basically taking on a
bunch of the responsibility
that we would previously
have offloaded to you
in terms of still providing that compute,
still providing the availability zone,
the network, the storage, et cetera.
The ECS control plane
that's managing your
application provisioning.
But then on top of that, we're
also managing things like
the compute, auto scaling,
the distribution and placement.
We create launch templates for you.
We're managing the patching
of your EC2 instances, et cetera,
but we're giving you the flexibility
to be able to make choices
about what compute you need.
So really, the intention
here is to try and find that,
to deliver that sweet spot
between the ECS and EC2,
and the Fargate experience.
And we believe that we've got that right.
We're waiting for your feedback
to make sure that we did.
The way that ECS manages and vents compute
through these compute
engines into your cluster
is through capacity providers.
A capacity provider is a configuration
that you describe, which
talks about the kind
of underlying compute that you need,
and then you associate
that capacity provider
either with your cluster
or with your ECS service.
Or if you're taking
control of the scheduling
and you're using a run task,
you can also provide
that capacity provider
through the run task API.
Today or previous to the launch
of ECS managed instances,
ECS delivered two capacity providers.
There was the ESG,
the managed ESG capacity provider,
which is effectively managing
the order scaling group
that you bring, and vending and leveraging
that auto scaling group
in order to vent compute
into your ECS cluster,
in a form of EC2 instances.
And then every cluster comes
with a default capacity provider,
which is the Fargate
capacity provider, right?
Which you can select, that
is the default experience.
And so if you're launching a task
into a cluster without
a capacity provider,
typically, you're you're
gonna land on Fargate.
With managed instances,
we've doubled down on that.
So we've introduced a new
capacity provider called
the ECS managed instances
capacity provider.
And again, that sits between
the ECS managed order scaling
and the ECS Fargate capacity provider.
It's an additional capacity provider type.
These all work together
if that's your choice.
And you know, one of the things
that we really wanna make sure
that we do well at AWS
is we really want to give you choice.
We, you know, we acknowledge
that there is no one
size fits all solution.
All of you bring value to your customers,
and to your business
because of the diversity of
the solution that you have.
And so we want to give you the choices
that you need in order
to be able to make sure
that we meet you where you are.
And so that's really why we
deliver this set of choices.
Now the thing with ECS managed instances
is we rarely wanted to optimize
for that Fargate experience,
but keep in mind that
there is this continuum,
and we're somewhere in the middle, right?
So there's always gonna be
slightly more configuration
than the pure Fargate experience
where you're just
configuring your application.
So the way that you go about configuring
an ECS managed instances capacity provider
is you'll provide to us as a minimum,
two IM roles.
The first role is the instance role.
That role is actually used and associated
with the EC2 instances that we provision
that gives you the permissions,
that gives that instance the permissions
it needs in order to talk back
to the ECS control plane
to that management layer,
effectively allows the agent
that you have the ECS agent
that you have running on that box
to be able to talk back,
get the configuration
that it needs for your cluster,
register with that cluster,
and then be able to actually
work with the scheduler,
to be able to provision tasks.
The other role that you give us is
the infrastructure management role.
And that's really you giving us permission
to take responsibility
for vending, for managing
these EC2 resources in your account.
Now the thing with ECS
managed instances is
that it's built on top
of EC2 managed instances.
EC2 managed instances is
a mechanism, a capability
that EC2 delivered last year,
which allows a managed service like ECS
to be able to manage EC2
instances in your account.
So when ECS managed
instances is provisioning
these EC2 instances,
you can see them when you describe them,
when you call describe instances,
you can see them in your list.
When you look at the EC2 console,
you'll see the instances there.
And you know,
we really like that transparency.
We like to be able to
make sure that you're able
to see what it is that we're doing.
You know, we're not hiding anything here.
You will see when you
look at those instances
that they're tagged as managed
and they'll be managed by ECS.
And you could exclude
those from, you know,
from having to worry about them,
because the reality is
that we are taking care
of all of that.
When you provision your capacity provider
in into your cluster,
one of the things that we've indexed on,
we do this with Fargate as well,
is that your capacity provider is
going to be using spread
placement by default.
We believe spread placement
is the right approach.
It allows you to make sure
that you're maximizing your availability.
And so the way that you do this,
in the same way that you
would with your ECS service
when you're provisioning
your ECS service for Fargate
and specifying the subnets that you want,
when each subnet specifies the
underlying availability zone
that the task will be launched in.
With the ECS managed
instance capacity provider,
you're specifying a set of
subnets that we are going
to use in order to provision EC2 instances
into those availability zones.
That makes, and then we will use that
to do spread placement.
Effectively, once you've
created your capacity provider,
given us those two roles
and associate it with your
service or your cluster,
at that point you're
just talking services,
and now, it's just like Fargate.
You create your ECS service,
your task definition, your provision,
and off the back of what you need,
we will go off and we'll go
down to EC2 managed fleets.
We'll get the capacity you need,
we'll provision it into the cluster,
and you're good to go.
We'll start landing tasks on it.
The way that we make decisions about
what EC2 instance to use
is really what we've done
is we've had a look at
what the vast majority
of customers end up using
when they're using EC2 managed instances,
and also with consideration
as to what it is
that we're provisioning
under the hood for Fargate.
And we've come up with a list of defaults.
And so unless you actually have a need
for specialist compute,
unless you actually need to be
a little bit more prescriptive.
You could just leave us to take care of
what instances are available,
and we're typically gonna choose
from any one of the C, M, or R families,
so the general purpose compute families.
We're gonna make sure that we're making
that choice based on your workload,
and we'll get a little
bit more into exactly
how we go about making that choice.
However, if you do need more control,
and this goes back to
this idea that, you know,
we're sitting on that continuum,
we wanna make sure that we're giving you
the flexibility that you need.
If you need more control, if
you need to be able to specify
that you need a specific
compute type, well,
ECS managed instances allows
you to capture that as a set,
using attribute based selection.
If you're familiar with
EC2's auto scaling groups
and fleet configurations, then you'll know
that attribute based
selection is a mechanism
that you can use to describe
the kind of EC2 instance
that you might want
without actually specifically stating
that EC2 instance, right?
So you can,
as part of attribute based selection,
specify that you want
a specific C648x large
if that's what you want,
but you can more generally describe
the kinds of compute that you want.
And the reason that that's really powerful
to try and be as general as possible
is because it gives us at ECS
the opportunity to make sure
that we find the capacity you need
with a broader, more diverse selection.
So the key here is really that
you can be as prescriptive as you want
with the compute that you want,
or you can be as general as you want,
or you can just leave it up to us, right?
That really goes to that shared
responsibility continuum.
The more prescriptive you
become, the harder it can be
for us to make sure that we're getting you
the lowest cost, most available instance.
And so in some workloads,
that's absolutely required.
You know, it may be that you need a GPU,
and you need that GPU,
and so you specifically have to target
that particular instance type.
You can do that with
ECS managed instances.
At the same time, if you
really just have a general
requirement for something
that's network optimized,
well, you wanna try and
probably be as broad as possible
because the benefit you get is that
that offloads the decision making to us.
And then what we'll do is
we can actually go to EC2,
and make sure that we're
getting you that compute.
So really the rule of thumb here is
as you're using this,
try and be as general as you can be,
'cause that maximizes
the availability posture
of the service.
It gives us a much better chance
of getting you the compute
that's available at any point in time.
The way that we go about
making decisions about how
to size the instance that we
need, how to get that compute
for you is we use the task
definition configuration.
So unlike with with ASGs
and managed order scaling groups
where you're actually
specifying the EC2 instances,
and then we're just placing the tasks.
Here, we're actually using
the task definition to be able
to decide what EC2
instances to get for you.
And the way that that works
is if you think back to
how task definitions are configured,
perhaps some of you have memorized this
quite as detailed as I have.
But basically the way this works is that
at a container level, keeping in mind
that you can have multiple
containers in your task,
you can specify as a minimum
the memory reservation for that container.
Now, the memory reservation for
the container is the amount,
the minimum amount of memory
that is reserved for that container.
It doesn't prescribe an upper bound,
it's just saying I need at least x.
You can then add to that,
the memory reservation,
the the memory that you
need for the container,
which is the upper bound.
And now you're saying this container needs
to be bounded to this amount of memory.
Also at the container level,
you can specify the CPU you need.
Now the thing with the CPU
that you need is it's not a hard cap
of this amount of CPU.
For the container,
the way that this is configured is
it becomes a ratio of the CPU available
to all of the containers in that task.
So it's ratioed across
all of those containers.
And so that's useful
if you have containers
that are kind of bursty,
they need to kind of consume,
you know, more or less.
But it also means that
you can make sure that
one of your containers,
perhaps your primary container
is getting 80% of the compute
and maybe your log or whatever it is is,
is getting less of their compute.
At the task level,
you can specify memory and CPU,
and that actually then,
this is how Fargate works.
That is actually specifying
exactly how much memory
and CPU will be allocated to that task.
It's effectively a hard bound.
And so the way that we
go about doing this is
when you configure your ECS, your task,
for ECS managed instances,
we walk through the set
of configuration that you have
and we decide based on that
what it is that we can go and get for you.
As a minimum, you have to
specify memory reservation
because we will then go
and find an EC2 instance
that's gonna fit it at least that.
But you can specify any
one of these things,
and it's valuable to actually try
and move higher up the stack.
The less you can be prescriptive
about what you're getting,
the more elastic you end up getting,
in terms in terms of
the underlying compute.
The difference between Fargate,
where you're getting that compute
and managed instances is
that with managed instances,
these workloads are multi-tenant.
They're gonna rely,
there'll be multiple of these,
of your tasks running on
the same EC2 instance.
And that's valuable,
because it allows you,
depending on how you specify
this, to allow those workloads
to burst from one to the other.
I was chatting to a gentleman earlier.
He was telling me about Java workloads
and the fact that they run a lot of Java.
A lot of Java,
especially when it's doing
just in time compilation
can burst CPU quite high
when it first starts out.
And what we found, customers
have told us with Fargate,
the end result is you actually have
to specify the CPU need at P100,
effectively the maximum CPU you need.
Using ECS managed
instances, you can allow,
we can leverage the elasticity
of the underlying compute
so that you can actually
specify less memory,
you can specify your aggregate
memory that you need,
and it'll allow you to burst,
to be able to handle that jet compilation.
Let's talk a little bit
about how we go about
making the decisions as to
what instance to launch.
Now one of the things that we really,
really index heavily on
is in order to make sure
that we're delivering you
the most resilient service,
we want to make sure that we
can provision your workloads
as fast as we possibly can.
That's our goal.
And effectively,
as you scale up, as
your service scales up,
we wanna be able to make sure
that we're launching those
tasks quickly because we
wanna get the workloads there
to make sure that they're
meeting your customer demand.
So the way we go about doing this is
at a point in time,
now keep in mind that a big cluster,
depending on the size of your clusters,
large clusters are very active.
There's workload going on all the time.
There's multiple services,
there's scaling up and scaling down.
So at any point in time,
the ECS scheduler will be having a look
to see what work needs to be done.
It takes a snapshot of all of the tasks
that are currently in a
pending state, basically tasks
that need to be
provisioned onto workloads.
And it's gonna index on making sure
that we first use the
compute that's already there.
And the reason for that, again,
goes to we wanna make sure
that we're launching your instance,
your tasks as quickly as we can.
So if we can fit the tasks
that you have on the instances
that you have while meeting
your placement constraints.
So making sure that we're spread AZ,
making sure that we're, if, you know,
whatever placement
constraints you've applied,
distinct instance, et cetera,
we'll make sure that we are first
landing on the compute that's there.
What we do next is we then
look at all of those tasks
that we were unable to place.
We look at the placement
constraints that have been applied
to those tasks, including their need
for availability zone spread.
And we will then go to EC2,
and based on your capacity,
your managed instances capacity
provider specifications,
we will get all of the EC2 instances
that meet that requirement.
We then do what we call
first fit descending,
first fit decreasing rather,
where what we'll do is walk through
the set of the set of tasks
that need to be placed,
and we'll look for the
largest EC2 instance
that meets those requirements
in order to place it.
So our goal is spread placement first.
In fact, first phase is
place on what we have.
Second phase is spread placement,
and then third phase is gonna be bin pack.
And the reason for that is
because we wanna make sure
that we're optimizing cost for you.
We wanna make sure that we're
finding the largest instance
at the best possible price,
and putting as much onto it as we can.
Let's move on a little bit,
talk a little bit about how
that can be optimized.
So the benefit that we get
in using these larger instances is,
and in using ECS manage
instances is you're actually
reusing that underlying compute.
And that's incredibly valuable,
because it goes to what
we were saying earlier
about the fact that we
wanna launch quickly,
we wanna get you running quickly.
There's two upsides there.
The one is you've got this
elasticity that we talked about
because you've got the larger instance,
so you can burst into it if you need.
Because you're landing
all of your workloads
on this instance,
the first workload will pull the image,
and the subsequent workloads
are gonna use that image cache.
And in fact, if you had multiple
of the same task landing
on the same EC2 instance,
those subsequent tasks are actually
reusing the image that's already there.
It saves you a bunch of time.
You're not putting that
image cache every time.
This significantly improves throughput.
And that's really why we
index hard on the, you know,
it's a combination of cost
and throughput that really leads us
to index quite heavily on making sure
that we're choosing a
larger instance type.
One of the things that we will be doing
in your cluster on sort
of an ongoing basis
is we're gonna be doing host replacement.
Remember, we talked about the fact that
there's this continuum, this
shared responsibility model,
and you know, part of this offering is
that you've offloaded
to us the responsibility
of making sure that your host is patched
and that your host is, is compliant.
And so we're gonna be
looking at opportunities
to be able to make sure
that we're meeting that
compliance requirement.
At the same time, there
are a bunch of other things
that could be going on that
actually drive the need
for replacing the host.
The first is that as an
operator, you may decide
that you don't particularly
want this particular host.
For some reason you decide
that you wanna get rid of that one,
and so you can actually drain the host,
can select it, deregister,
or force deregister,
and then we would run it through
what we call a drain cycle
or a host replacement cycle.
Another is maintenance events.
And so ECS is continually monitoring
to see if there are EC2 maintenance events
applied to that particular EC2 instance,
so that we need to replace it.
Or maintenance is a result
of patching, you know,
where the operating system
needs to be patched.
And so we'll be applying those.
There's auto scaling,
so your service is continually
scaling up and scaling down.
And as you scale up and scale down,
we need to make sure that
we're taking corrective action.
And then there's cost optimization.
We're continually looking for
opportunities to make sure
that we're giving you
the best possible value.
We don't want idle
instances sitting around.
So the way that this
works is that effectively,
at the point that we get a notification
that an an instance needs to be replaced
for whatever reason,
we enter the draining life cycle.
And the first two of the
scheduler is gonna do
is it's going to try and replace,
it's going to replace all of the tasks
that are managed,
running on that on that instance.
We always make sure,
again, going to resilience,
we always start a task
before we stop a task.
It's sort of a golden rule that we have.
We have this conversation
with the schedule team all the time.
It is the golden rule.
We start things before we
stop things to make sure
that we're always meeting your minimum
healthy requirement for your service.
That we're always meeting
your resiliency goals.
So the way that this will
work is the scheduler
is gonna first launch a bunch of tasks.
Now let's assume in this
particular case there isn't
enough compute in your cluster.
Those tasks are gonna go into pending,
and we're gonna go back
through that workflow
that we were talking about earlier
where we're going to have,
we're gonna look for the capacity,
the compute that we need,
find the compute
that meets the placement requirements
for these particular tasks,
and provision that into the cluster.
We are then going to
provision those tasks onto
this EC2 instance.
Now you'll notice here
that we've provisioned
the orange and the green
tasks, the service tasks,
the managed tasks.
What we have not done is
provisioned the unmanaged task.
So if you launch a task
onto ECS using a run task
or start task, then the
way that we think about
that is effectively, that's
a mechanism to tell us
that your service is taking
responsibility for scheduling.
So rather than using our scheduler,
you want to own the scheduling through
some some external, external process.
And so we don't take,
we don't manage those tasks.
What we will do is we will make sure
that those tasks are the
last to be deprovisioned,
and we will always honor the
task shut down grace period.
And any of the mu text functionality.
So the task scale-in protection,
the task that you've got enabled.
So if a task, if a run,
if a unmanaged task is currently
in its shutdown grace period,
or it's currently in a
scale-in protection phase,
we won't take corrective action
until it's exited that phase.
Unmanaged tasks are also the last things
to be deprovisioned off the instance.
So the first thing we'll be doing is
we go and find new tasks for you.
The schedule will
replace the managed tasks
on the new capacity,
then it'll tear down the managed tasks.
And then the very last thing,
honoring these constraints.
What'll do is it'll then tear down
the actual unmanaged tasks.
Once we've done that,
we're then gonna actually
tear down the EC2 instance.
And that gets us back to a point where
you know, your processes, your services
is up and running,
and we've removed any of that.
The idle compute that you no longer need.
Now one of the things
that you might notice
in your services, remember
we talked a little bit about
the fact that we're
optimizing for throughput.
And so we're, so, you know,
we really wanna make sure
that we're launching quickly,
but as a side effect of that,
when we launch, it may be
that in fact that the
distribution of compute
that you have in your
cluster doesn't align
with the distribution of pure balance
that you'd need for your ECS service.
And so your service can end,
for a short period of time,
in an unbalanced state.
ECS is continually looking for
opportunities to rebalance.
And so just before re:Invent last year,
we launched a feature
for ECS services called
continual rebalance,
where where you can actually
select for that service
that you want to be rebalanced.
This is now a default behavior.
And again, it goes to what
we were saying earlier.
We try very hard to bake in,
we work to bake in default best practice
as default into the service.
And so this is a best practice,
and for any new service
that you create, it will
automatically rebalance.
And so what's gonna happen there is that
the schedule is looking
for these opportunities.
It's going to identify the fact
that this particular
service is unbalanced,
and then it will take corrective action
to make sure that it replaces,
it rebalances that service
by launching a new task first
into the appropriate availability zone
and tearing down the the previous task.
And again, that'll kick off
that workflow if you need new compute.
Well, in that particular
case, we're gonna go off
and get an EC2 instance and
we're gonna make sure we put it
right where it needs to be
in that availability zone,
so we can provision onto that instance
for you, and make sure that
you're continually balanced.
And as a result you will
end up in a world where,
you know, you're continually
meeting that availability requirement.
Your tasks are always appropriately spread
across the availability
zones that you've configured.
One of the things that we watch for
on an ongoing basis is a notion
that we call idle hosts.
And idle hosts, really,
is just to make sure
that we don't end up in a position
where we've deprovisioned
a bunch of tasks,
and we've got a bunch of
EC2 capacity sitting around.
'Cause that's just wasting,
it's wasteful, it's wasting your money.
And so the way we do
that the ECS scheduler
is continually monitoring for stop events.
Effectively, anytime a task is terminated,
we know that there's an
opportunity potentially
for us to go and do some optimization,
to apply some optimization.
And so as soon as we see that event,
we'll go and do a sweep
of the entire cluster.
We'll identify opportunities
where we think we can
actually do a better job,
and we will move tasks to make sure
that we're packed appropriately.
Again, honoring spread
and placement constraints.
And then deprovision those tasks.
We will deprovision those instances.
Again, honoring stop before stop.
The other thing that we will be doing is
we look for opportunities to downscale.
So if you're running on a
larger instance, say, you know,
many workloads may be diurnal,
so you scale up during the day,
you need larger instances,
you need more capacity.
But as you get to the end of the day,
your service scales in, your
customers are, you know,
customer demand has dropped.
And so during that case,
we're gonna end up in a position where
those EC2 instances are no longer needed.
It may be, you know,
there's two ways to do that.
We may be deprovisioning.
The other is that we may
actually just scale down.
And so we would choose a
new instance type for you,
and actually move you onto
that new instance type,
that smaller instance type
in order to save you money.
So let's talk a little bit about
how we do patching.
One of the things that, you know,
we talked about is we wanna take on
that responsibility for patching.
Our customers have told us,
you know, I wanna make sure
that I'm compliant, but actually,
keeping your EC2 instance patched,
your Amazon machine image
patched is hard work,
and there's a lot that goes into that,
and it generally doesn't tend
to be differentiated
work for many businesses.
You know, it's not the
thing that's gonna really,
really make you shine,
it's just busy work.
It's incredibly important work.
And so we wanna take
on that responsibility.
And so one of the key features
that ECS managed instances delivers
is this patching workflow.
Now the way that this works is
we wanna make sure that
within a 30 day period,
we have patched all of your capacity.
On day zero, at the point
that you provision your task,
we're gonna give you a
brand new EC2 instance.
We always favor provisioning
new instances over.
We never patch in place.
We always provision a new instance.
And the reason for that
is because under the hood,
EC2 has its fleet of available capacity
against which it is continually
running health checks.
And so getting a new
EC2 instance means that
that health checks have
recently been applied to that.
And so it's going to be
a good, healthy instance.
We're not gonna vent
one that is unhealthy.
So we're gonna give you,
we're gonna give you a healthy instance,
and then we're gonna give you the latest
Amazon machine image that we are using.
ECS managed instances is
built on Bottlerocket.
Again, going to that shared
responsibility model,
the thing with ECS managed instances is
you don't get to bring your own army.
We deliver the army because again,
we need to make sure
that we understand how
that army works because we
need to be able to patch it
and deploy it and run your workloads on it
in a way that ensures
that you're gonna get
the outcome that you need.
And so if you do need to
manage your own Amazon machine image,
well, ECS and EC2 is
probably a good fit for you.
But in many cases, customers
don't need that responsibility.
The Amazon machine image,
the army that we're using is Bottlerocket.
Bottlerocket is AWS's
container optimized operating system.
We delivered, in fact, that
team works very closely
with with our ECS container
and our EKS teams to make sure
that we're continually
delivering the most optimal
configuration that we can.
So under the hood, we're gonna
be giving you the latest,
the latest up to date Bottlerocket image.
We're gonna deliver that on day zero.
And then 14 days after that,
we're going to start to
look for opportunities
to be able to patch that.
And really, that's because
we wanna fit into this
30 day patch cycle.
We wanna make sure that
we've always replaced
all of your armies within
a period of 30 days,
because that rarely helps with meeting,
making sure that we're meeting
your compliance requirements
for those of you in regulated industries
that have that pressing requirement.
At day 14, we start looking
for these opportunities
to be able to optimize,
to be able to replace these instances.
Now one of the things that we do is
ECS on managed instances honors
the EC2 maintenance window.
So for those of you that
have used EC2 extensively,
you've probably encountered
EC2 maintenance windows.
It's a mechanism that you can
use to be able to configure
and tell us when is a good
time for us to be able
to take corrective action
for your underlying compute.
And so as a minimum, you
need to give us two windows
within a one week period
where we can go and take
that corrective action.
ECS managed instances is
leveraging that configuration
so you can configure through
EC2 managed instances when you want us
to take this corrective action,
and we're only going to
take the corrective action
during that period.
So obviously you can optimize
for weekends or downtimes
or whatever it is that works best for you.
Sort of your low traffic points in a day.
At that 14 day period,
we're gonna give you, like I said,
brand new instance,
and we're gonna give you a brand new army.
It is possible that over that period,
that we haven't got to everything,
although under most circumstances,
we will have completed that patch cycle.
It's also important to keep in mind
that this patch cycle isn't
everything in your cluster
on launch day zero,
day 14, everything in your cluster, right?
It's an ongoing process.
So we're continually evolving,
we're continually making sure
that your cluster is okay.
So you'll see, you'll see a fair degree
of mutation in your cluster
as we taking this corrective action.
It's not high mutation,
but there's an ongoing background mutation
as we manage that entropy for you,
as we take on the
responsibility of making sure
that we are keeping you compliant.
At day 21, we start
to get a little bit more aggressive,
'cause we've made a commitment to you
that we will make sure
that we keep you compliant
within this 30 day window.
So at day 21, we're actually gonna start
taking corrective action
where we're going to start
doing effectively eviction,
where we'll find the instance that needs
to be patched and then
we'll move workloads off it
and patch it.
And at that point,
so typically we're gonna be
honoring maintenance windows
between day 14 and day 21.
So it's very unlikely
that that we wouldn't.
But at day 21, we need to start
being a little bit more aggressive,
because we have to replace that army.
And then, you know, having
completed that cycle,
we then get to a point where
you now have a clean, healthy cluster.
All of your instances are
replaced, they're all replaced
with brand new instances,
and you're currently running
the latest and greatest
of the Bottlerocket army.
So one of the things that you
might be asking yourself is,
well, that's great.
There's like this continuum,
and I've got all these decisions point,
like, you know,
now I've got a bunch of things to decide
when would I use one versus the other.
Our recommendation is
that more often than not,
most customers are best served by Fargate.
Typically customers, you know,
'cause typically your workload,
especially if it's a stateless workload,
especially if it's CPU and memory bound,
you can get everything
that you need from Fargate.
And so that's where we would
recommend that you start.
It's simple.
It works.
Customers love it.
If you find that you have a need
either to have a larger instance,
a larger task size,
so Fargate has upper bounds
in terms of the amount of VCPU and memory
that it will configure,
and you need something bigger.
ECS managed instances is for you.
Equally if you need control
over the underlying compute,
if you really wanna make
sure that you are choosing
that particular instance type,
or that family of instance types.
Or you know, for example if you need
accelerated instance types,
you need GPUs, et cetera.
ECS managed instances
is a really good fit.
It's the sweet spot between
that Fargate experience
and the ability to be able to own
and manage the configuration that you need
in order to get that
compute that you need.
For those customers that need
to manage the actual operating system.
Effectively, you wanna be
able to bring your own army.
You wanna be able to tune the kernel
or whatever it is.
ECS on managed instances is for you.
That is probably the small minority.
There are very few cases
where that is needed,
but if it is needed, you have that option.
So the way we're thinking about this is
we think a lot of customers today
that needed that additional functionality
that Fargate wasn't quite
able to deliver in terms
of the instance type selection,
and are currently running on ECS on EC2.
Managed instances is probably a great fit,
and that migration is fairly seamless.
So, you know, we'd encourage
you to have a look at that.
At the same time, those customers that are
running on Fargate and get to a point
where you feel like you need more compute
than Fargate is able to deliver,
or you need something
that's optimized for network
or optimized for storage throughput,
ECS managed instances
is a great fit for you as well.
So it's sort of the sweet
spot between those two.
With that, I'm gonna hand over
to my friend and colleague Maish.
Thank you all.
- Thank you very much, Malcolm.
Everybody hear me okay?
Perfect, okay.
So we've been talking about
infrastructure up until now,
and I want to move over
to the software part,
which essentially is
again, on that continuum
of the shared responsibility.
This actually is your responsibility.
We still, as part of the
shared responsibility model,
still provide you with the
infrastructure underneath
that allows you to continue
to provision your software
as part of your application,
which you're providing.
And in November, we
kind of revamped the way
we do in Amazon ECS deployments.
The reason that, of course
is because, of course,
feedback from our customers.
They had some challenges
with the way we were doing it.
It was dependent on an external service
called CodeDeploy.
And we wanted to give you a
more streamlined experience.
And just in the beginning of last month,
we provided that experience,
which is called ECS deployments
with three different options for you
to deploy your services
and upgrade your
applications running on ECS.
Blue/green deployments,
linear deployments,
and canary deployments.
So we're gonna go through each
one of these in some detail
to explain exactly what it is,
but first, of course,
an overview for those who are not
people who usually do this
for the day to day life.
A blue/green deployment is
you have a blue service running
in production across
multiple availability zones.
You would like to upgrade the service.
In that case,
you provision a new
version of that service
across the availability zones,
meeting your requirements,
and when you're ready,
you take that service
and flip it between a load
balancer to the new one,
and direct all your traffic
to the new green service.
And when you're ready, remove
the previous one in blue.
Simple process.
But let's go and fall into
a little bit more detail
into how this actually works.
There are six different stages
of a deployment in Amazon ECS.
The preparations phase.
Sorry, preparation stage,
deployment, testing, traffic shift,
and monitoring and completion.
In the preparation stage, we go back
to the fact you have one
version, which is blue,
running a hundred percent of your traffic,
and at a hundred percent capacity
in your ECS cluster.
When you start a deployment,
we will start to pre-scale up.
The pre-scale up in this case
will not provision any resources.
And again, these are very distinct phases
within the deployment process as part,
and you can get status on each
and every single one of
these different phases.
We will provision the
infrastructure underneath,
where in this case, is
preparing the routing rules
in the load balancer
and the target groups,
but we will not yet start
to provision resources.
This is the preparation phase.
Deployment phase has two different things.
In this case, when we
start the deployment phase,
we will start the scale
up of the green version,
where we will provision a
hundred percent of the capacity.
And again, it's always
the a hundred percent
of capacity which we are
provisioning in the background
for the very simple reason, of course,
we want to provide you the capability
of always having enough capacity
to move over when you're
moving to a new version.
In this case, of course,
the post scale up,
we will verify that the green
service has been started,
and that the a hundred
percent of the traffic
is still being routed to the blue version,
and no traffic is being
moved over to green.
During a testing phase, we'll validate
that the green environment is able
to actually accept traffic
by injecting some test
traffic into the load balancer,
which will start verifying
that actually it is working,
and able to respond.
All the health checks are passing,
and your application is behaving
and performing the way
you expect it to do that.
You'll see at the bottom
there is a smaller lambda icon
because at what we have
tried to provide for you
is the ability at every single stage
of the deployment or a
phase of the deployment,
the possibility to run your own tests.
And these are done
in what we call deployment
lifecycle hooks.
And the deployment lifecycle
hooks is essentially
a lambda function,
which you can configure
or define as part of the
deployment of what you want
that lambda facts
function to actually test
or verify is working.
So for example, essentially it is
actually just code.
For like any other lambda
code where you will provide
the criteria for what, is it passed,
if it's currently in progress,
if it failed, and what to do.
And once it either passes
that phase or fails,
it'll automatically roll back
or continue to the next phase.
This can be, for example,
to verify that the SHA
that you are looking for
on your container image
matches the one that you're actually
supposed to be deploying,
and there's no in discrepancy,
or that the target
groups have already been
validated and actually
exist on the load balancer
so that I know that everything is working.
These are the tests that
you can define exactly
what you would like them to be.
Traffic shift.
So we verified that everything is working
and now we start to move the traffic.
In a blue/green, of course,
we said was a hundred percent capacity
was running to blue,
and we flip it at one time in one shot
for moving all the capacity over to green.
So in this case, now zero is
running to the blue version,
and all the a hundred percent
traffic is now running
again, to the green version.
And again, we have these
deployment lifecycle hooks
where we can validate that
everything is actually working.
We then go into a bake
time or a monitoring phase.
In other words, we want to see actually
that everything has,
performing the way it was.
This can be of course some
kind of a performance,
maybe a degradation test.
Is my application
performing exactly the way
it should be like it was before?
If there's any degradation in performance,
I want to automatically
re-roll back directly
to my previous version because
it's still sitting there,
but there's no traffic running to it.
So the switch backward and
forward is almost instantaneous,
and allows you to gain the confidence
and be very, very confident
that you can actually
not have any problems.
And if they are,
roll back directly very quickly without
hurting or hitting any of
your of your customers,
hitting a performance issue.
The last one of course
is the cleanup phase.
The cleanup phase is after we
verify that everything is done
and over here specifically a cleanup,
there is no deployment lifecycle hook,
because this is the last
stage of the deployment.
Once we're ready, we know
that everything is working.
We can finally deprovision
all the resources
which we had on our previous version,
and then green becomes blue,
and we continue the
process to the next one,
to the next version going forward.
Linear deployments.
Similar.
Blue version, which you wanna start
running a hundred percent of my traffic.
I would like to start
slowly gradually moving
traffic to my new version.
I provision a new version,
and slowly move my traffic.
25% of the time you can do
the definition of however much of traffic
you would like to do.
Over time moving more and more
and more traffic over to my new version
until I get to the fact
that everything is moved,
and then I can de deprovision
my previous version
and work with this kind of
process on a regular basis.
So let's dive in again.
The first part is exactly
the same as we saw before.
The preparation, deployment,
and testing phase,
but it is slightly different
on the traffic shift.
So let's zoom in over there for a second,
and have a look what it looks like.
In the traffic shift,
we start in the beginning with
a hundred percent capacity
running to blue, zero percent per traffic
running to green.
We start moving our traffic.
As part of the deployment,
we have a definition of a bake time.
Again, this is an amount of time
where you want the application to sit
on both versions
to see that actually
everything is working.
And again, with the
deployment lifecycle hooks,
you can validate after every
single one of these steps
of the traffic shift,
you can validate that
everything is working.
Again, if anything fails,
we'll fail back all together
back to the regional version,
so you would not have any
degradation of service.
And it continues per
each amount of traffic
or the weighting of the load balancer
moving more and more and more
traffic to the new version,
until we finally complete
and get to moving all of our traffic over
to our new version that we've run.
This is the linear.
So we go step by step by step by step
in order for us to do this.
The last one I wanna look is canary.
It's similar, it's a kind of
a mixture of both of the two.
Where we have a hundred percent
running on our blue version,
we want to deploy a new
service, we deploy a new one,
but we only move a bit of the traffic,
in this case, 10% for example.
And we let that sit to verify
that everything is okay,
and once we are confident enough,
we're are gonna flip everything at once,
the rest of the remainder of the traffic.
So it's pretty much just
a two or three step,
depends on how you look at it.
Two or three step motion where you only
do one migration of traffic or part of it.
And once you're confident enough
that everything is working,
then you'll flip all the other traffic.
And again, too, and afterwards
remove the the blue service.
Again, zooming in on
the actual traffic shift
because this is the only different change
that we have.
In the beginning,
we have a hundred percent
running to our blue version,
no traffic going to green.
We move some of the traffic,
in this case 10%,
over to the one version.
And again, we have the bake time.
This is what we are
there to run your tests,
run your validations to see
that everything is working
correctly the way you expect it is.
Let it sit, validate the
performance is working
as it should be.
And once you are confident enough
and have got the correct metrics
and everything that you need,
then you can flip everything
over to the new version.
And allow you to migrate your
service to a new version.
We like to provide,
ECS is what we call
best practice by design.
Everything Malcolm has been talking about
the fact of start before stop,
placement mechanisms,
how we actually do the
updates of software,
of the instances, everything,
that best practices
which we internally use
for our own fleets and our own services.
We want to provide that
option for you as a customer
to use those same primitives as well.
And by the provisioning of
resources in each version,
for example, best practices by design,
the lifecycle hooks allow
you to gain that confidence.
We give you that opportunity.
Again, I try to refer back to that
shared responsibility model
of we're taking on toil
and giving you some of it,
but we are giving you the options.
So for example, you have to validate
that everything is working correctly,
and you have to provide that code.
It's that shared responsibility model,
but we are giving you the options
and the mechanisms in order for
you to allow you to do that.
The bake time as well
is also best practice internally.
We do that for every single
one of our deployments.
We are also giving you that opportunity
and that primitive
to allow you to also make
use of that mechanism
as well to validate your
applications are working correctly.
So as Malcolm asks,
we have different spectrums
of what you can use.
So a question that a lot
of customers come to us,
when do I do blue/green,
when do I do linear, when do I do canary?
And as any good IT person
will say, it depends.
Obviously.
There are benefits
of one version over the other,
and it will depend on
your kind of application.
We look at blue/green
mainly optimized for speed.
If I want to actually
move over to a new version
very, very quickly, this will
be the fastest way to do it.
It will of course require you
to have a robust deployment mechanism
and validate that everything is working
because once you switch,
you're switching all of the traffic,
and that could cause a
problem if there is some kind
of degradation or bug inside your system.
When we look at linear, this is kind of,
we have to be, I want to
be a bit more conservative.
I want to do it slowly
and move my customers
or my traffic over to actually gain.
I'm not a hundred percent
sure how this works.
It'll take me more time to validate
that the traffic is working,
there's no degradation of performance.
Those kind of things,
I wanna be a little bit more conservative.
But on the other hand,
this will take more time.
Your deployment time will be longer,
and the rollover to a new version
of a service will be longer.
And as a result, of course,
because we are provisioning
as we said, a hundred percent
of capacity on both versions,
you'll be paying a
slightly bit longer amount,
slightly bit more for that amount,
and that both resources are
sitting up in the air waiting
for the actual migration
of your service from
one version to another.
Canary is a kind of a mix of the two.
In other words, I wanted do quickly,
but I don't wanna wait so long
so I'll do a bit of my traffic.
I will validate that I know
exactly I'm confident enough
that if I do a bit of it and it moves
and everything is working fine,
then I'll move everything.
That's what our customers
kind of look for.
But it's not only on your own confidence
and your own operational practices,
it also kind of depends on
the application as well.
Because if I give you, for example,
your application has some kind of,
everybody talks about AI,
so let's talk about AI.
Some kind of LLM application.
In other words where you
are updating a version
of an LLM inside your application.
So if you do a migration
from one version of service
to the other and start
on linear for example,
there could be a chance
that the customer experience
coming to to these different services,
well, might be different
because the one LLM version
behaves slightly different
than the previous one.
So that might be a reason that
you, for example, would like
to do something which is more blue/green.
I want the the customer experience to be
as standard as possible
and not have any deviations
where customers could
get different answers.
For example, from an LLM,
then I would do a blue/green
to move as fast as possible
from one version to the other.
If it is an application, which
is a simple web application,
maybe upgrading one version
to another, then maybe
that will make much of a difference.
It would depend on the kind of software
that you're actually using.
Before we leave, we
would like to leave you
with a couple of QR codes and resources,
which we can actually dive deeper into
a lot of the topics which
we talked about today.
The first one is actually
the documentation,
which is very, very robust,
and gives a bit more
than I did actually today
with how exactly each of the stages are,
each of the phases are
exactly what you can do
and how you implement that.
On the right hand side,
on your right hand side is
blog posts, which we published about
a deep dive into ECS managed instances
with a lot of the information
that Malcolm provided today as well,
but not all of it.
And the last two are two
builder library articles.
A builder library is a website
where we have white papers
of how we build things in Amazon
on a regular basis.
Of course, without all the details,
but from the concept perspective,
if these are white
papers, which are written
by our principal engineers,
senior principal engineers,
distinguished, the top people in Amazon
who build systems which scale
to things like as we say,
3 billion tasks a week on a regular basis.
And the first one is about,
both are written about how we do
deployments internally in Amazon.
How you can ensure, for example,
rollback safety with deployments.
These are the kind of things
which we do on a regular basis
at huge scale in Amazon,
and we would like to provide
that information to you as well
so you can start reading about
and implement that as well
inside your own organizations.
We'd like to thank you very,
very much for your time.
Our emails are here up on the screen.
If you would like to take a picture,
send us an email.
If you have any questions.
We'd be more than happy to answer them.
And of course, before you leave,
and preferably before you leave,
or you can also do it on the way,
please don't forget to
give us the feedback
from the session itself
in the application,
the AWS events application.
We would really, really appreciate it
to hear back from you how the session was,
was it useful?
Is there any feedback you
would like to give us directly
about the actual session itself?
We'd be more than happy to hear from you.
And if there are any questions,
we will be somewhere over
there towards the entrance
of the hall,
so that we don't stop
the next session coming,
which is already lining up.
Thank you very much for your time
and enjoy the rest of
your day and your event.
- [Malcolm] Thank you.
(audience clapping)